♪♪
Lynsey:
I just never thought I would
come back here.
You don't got love for this
city?
♪♪
Lynsey:
It's not the city.
It's that house.
♪♪
I'm the only one that made it
out.
♪♪
Lynsey:
I-I got a job.
Gloria:
You did, doing what?
Lynsey:
Cleaning pools.
What are you doing?
Pools.
(Smacks lips)
Cleaning them.
James:
Look, if it get dark, now, you
just, you just ride it.
Okay?
Yeah.
-Yeah.
How do I do that?
(Chuckles)
♪♪
Alright, uh, what’s dark?
Lynsey:
I work for the Army Corp of
Engineers.
Lynsey:
Now I need them to clear me so I
can go back.
You got blown up over there and
you wanna’ go back?
♪I've got to get away from here
somehow.♪
♪I don't know know where I'm
gonna go.♪
What happened?
James:
I was in a car accident on the
causeway.
♪Whoa you just don't care.?
Lynsey:
I’m kind of on a lot of
medication.
James:
What kind of medication?
Like ‘don’t shoot yourself in
the head’ kind of medication.
Okay.
♪♪
♪I've got to get myself
together,♪
♪I gotta get through the stormy
weather.♪
♪I got to get away.♪
Dr. Lucas:
Can you go back? Yes.
Should you got back?
It's a different question.
♪Whoa, I just gotta get
away.♪
James:
How the pool business going?
It's cut-throat.
♪♪
Really?
No.